[Musique]
à la bibliothèque publique de new york
c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
changement de destination
au continent pas là assurez vous qu'il
soit accueilli par la conscience très
bien monsieur oui
le chien
bon chien
[Musique]
tu as compris que je gère cet
établissement n'est ce pas je suis
dispensé de tout service j'en ai plus
qu'assez de de [ __ ] des balles dans la
tête des gens je ne suis pas venu te
demander de tuer qui que ce soit je veux
juste que tu me conduisent jusqu'à lui
jusqu'à qui t'ont ancien patron tu veux
tuer berhad pâle tu es simplement lui
parler je peut se voir ce que tu
attendes lui exactement un conseil
écoute j'ai fait une promesse quand j'ai
pris la direction de cet hôtel et cette
promesse c'est de ne jamais enfreindre
les règles de la table si toi tu ne
désire pas le tuer c'est lui qui te
turas et très probablement mois avec
pour avoir conduit jusqu'à lui
[Applaudissements]